and i remember him saying i don't think
you can go and i said i can't be left
alone
hold it hold up there's several notes
there's several conversations there's a
conversation
meghan markle opened up to oprah winfrey
about her mental health struggles
you've said some pretty shocking things
here revealing
i wasn't planning to say anything
shocking i'm just telling you what's
happened
okay i'm sorry if it shocked you it's
been a lot i'm a little shocked
and revelations about megan's suicidal
thoughts let the iconic talk show host
stunned
look i was really ashamed to say it at
the time
and a shame to have to admit it to harry
especially
because i know how much loss he suffered
but i knew that if i didn't say it
that i would do it and i just didn't
i just didn't want to be alive anymore
the duchess of sussex detailed her
attempts to seek out professional help
and how she was met with denial and
indifference from buckingham palace
and i need to go somewhere and i was
told that i couldn't that it wouldn't be
good for the institution
so were you thinking of harming yourself
were you having suicidal thoughts
yes this was very very clear
megan got emotional when she recalled
one heartbreaking conversation with
harry
about her inner turmoil we had to go to
this event and i remember him saying i
don't think you can go and i said i
can't be left alone
because you were afraid of what you
might do to yourself so sorry to hear
that
after harry joined the interview oprah
took the prince to task for his initial
response to megan's struggles
i went to a very dark place as well do
you tell other people in the family i
need to get help for her we need
help that's just not a conversation that
would be had um i guess i was ashamed of
admitting it to them
i didn't have anyone to turn to harry
claimed his family didn't comprehend how
this was an unprecedented crisis for the
royal institution
we've all been through the pressure
we've all been through yes but what was
different
exploiting what was different for me was
the race element
because now it wasn't just about her but
it was about what she represents
and therefore it wasn't just affecting
my wife it was affecting
so many other people as well and for
megan there was a special purpose behind
the very personal revelation
i share this because
there are so many people who
are afraid to voice that they need help
and i know
personally how hard it is to not just
voice it but when you voice it to be
told
no i think at this point harry and megan
feel they have nothing to lose
last week it spoke with olmet scobee
co-author of the harry and meghan
biography
finding freedom who broke down why the
couple might be inclined to open up
about mental health in the interview
we've never heard them speak this is the
first time that we really
get to hear the emotional turmoil and
difficulty that came from those very
dark days
as working members of the royal family
megan as an
american as a woman who's very in touch
with her emotions
she even said herself like i couldn't do
the stiff upper lip thing and
you know when we look at harry who
really struggled with the death of his
mother
it was only when he lost that stiff
upper lip that he was really able to
deal with his own
issues and really get in touch with his
own mental health and
we've heard him talk about it a lot
since you know this is something that
harry and megan found time and time
again that
whenever they wanted to set the record
straight themselves or
at least answer back to some of the
really ugly
reports about them in the tabloids the
palace would come back to them and tell
them or remind them
of the no comment policy that's in place